[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 21 avril pour
faire face à la crise sanitaire et à un
nombre toujours important de patients
positifs aux convives 19 l' agence
régionale de santé a mis en place une
stratégie des programmes et les
opérations chirurgicales pour libérer
des lits
quelles conséquences cela a t'il nous
ferons le point avec nos invités
sandrine ronot secrétaire général de
l'association française des
polyarthritiques et vincent cluzeau
président de france aso santé ile de
france trois nouvelles navettes de
transport à la demande
viennent de s'ajouter aux trois déjà
existante dans l'agglomération
rambouillet territoire en circulation
depuis janvier 2021
ce mode de transport doit permettre à
des personnes en zones rurales d'accéder
aux centres des grandes villes et enfin
d'édition un peu d' aventure une vie
noise va participer à un trek 100%
féminin au coeur du désert marocain
le trekking gaz elle aura lieu du 6 au
11 novembre prochain juste avant cela le
gouvernement l'a confirmé ce matin la
sortie du conseil de défense à l'elysée
à partir du 3 mai plus besoin de compter
les kilomètres pour se déplacer
les restrictions de circulation en
journée vont être levé tout comme
l'interdiction des déplacements entre
régions cet allègement des restrictions
coïncidera avec la reprise des cours en
présentiel dans l'ensemble des
établissements scolaires français
[Musique]
pour continuer à faire face à cette
crise sanitaire et au nombre toujours
important de patients covit 19 positif à
l'hôpital des programmes et les
opérations chirurgicales pour libérer
des lits c'est la stratégie de l' agence
régionale de santé depuis le 12 mars
dernier et voir même depuis plus d'un an
sur ordre évidemment du ministère de la
santé
comme lors du premier confinement les
régulations de lits en soins critiques
et la répartition des patients se fait à
l'échelle régionale s'il y avait tsongo
journalistes de la rédaction fait le
point avec vous bonsoir bonsoir
alors d'abord combien d'opérations
chirurgicales ont été déprogrammés ces
dernières semaines bien nous sommes à 45
% de déprogrammation d'opérations
chirurgicales en ile de france
au sein de chaque hôpital et de chaque
clinique les déprogrammations sont des
décisions collégiales des équipes
médicales à l'hôpital de rambouillet
l'activité chirurgicale a baissé de 37%
c'est à peu près le même pourcentage
pour le centre hospitalier de versailles
quels types de prix d'opérations pardon
sont déprogrammés hier ce sont toutes
les opérations
finalement non urgentes qui nécessite
quand même une anesthésie générale ce
qu'on entend par là c'est beaucoup de
chirurgie orthopédique pose de prothèses
de hanche ou de genou mais aussi la
chirurgie bariatrique pour des patients
atteints d'obésité
cela peut être d'autres sortes
d'opérations de toute façon la décision
est prise après l'examen de la balance
bénéfice-risque des opérations lourdes
comme des opérations du coeur sont très
rarement des programmes et et on
comprend bien pourquoi la rs ile de
france a fixé des paliers également pour
augmenter les capacités de prise en
charge en soins critiques célia oui nous
sommes en avril au quatrième palier et
qui est fixé désormais à 2142 lieux de
soins critiques pour des patients
acolytes plus alors que le premier
palier de 676 lee avait été atteint le 5
février 2021
la montée en puissance des capacités de
soins critiques repose sur plusieurs
critères armée bien sûr plus de lits
avec le matériel adapté ventilateur
respirateur mais aussi augmenter la
capacité des personnels de soignants ce
qui est compliqué car partout désormais
les établissements de santé sont en
tension
est-ce que du coût des transferts de
patients ont été réalisés
en ile de france donc de l'île de france
vers d'autres régions peut-être c'est ça
oui 39 patients ont été évacués depuis à
la mi mars à d'ile-de-france en
hélicoptère ou en avion vers des
hôpitaux des régions dont les services
ne sont pas saturés
un dispositif d'accompagnement des
familles a été mise en place pour
prendre en charge notamment leurs frais
de déplacement mais aussi de logements
pour les visites aux proches
d'hospitalité hospitalisé merci célia
get on go journalistes de la rédaction
pour toutes ces précisions
et pour continuer à parler de ce sujet
des déprogrammations d'opérations
chirurgicales mais également de leurs
conséquences nous accueillons en
visioconférence avec nous sandrine rôle
au secrétaire général de l'association
française des polyarthritiques bonsoir
bonsoir avec nous également
visioconférence vincent plus au
président de l'association france aso
santé en ile-de-france bonsoir bonsoir
alors vincent plus vous plus au pardon
tout d'abord votre association france
aso santé a lancé un sondage il ya
quelques mois en novembre dernier
il indiquait que près de la moitié des
français 47% ont eu des soins annulés ou
reportés depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire comme notre journaliste célia
garçons gaulle a exposé ce sont
notamment les opérations non urgentes
quelle est la conséquence à court terme
de ces nombreuses annulations report sur
le moral notamment des passions qui ne
sont pas positifs au co vide alors c'est
un très très gros problème parce que né
il ya un stress qui s'installe chez les
patients qui auraient dû être opéré et
qui ne le sont pas et qui induit d un
mal être qui me semble un peu évident il
faut quand même savoir que nous avons
une occupation des lits en réa sur
l'ile-de-france 257% sur toute l'île de
france
ce qui veut dire que des
déprogrammations bien entendu son sont
importantes se sont pas seulement des
coûts des programmations d'opération
c'est aussi le renoncement aux soins de
certains patients particulièrement les
particulièrement dans le cas des cancers
où beaucoup de patients ont suspendu
leur chimio par peur de parts par de
fréquentes et l'hôpital et ça c'est
aussi très très très très important nous
avons une diminution de l'accès aux
soins de près de 50% aussi oui donc le
même résultat que c'est des
programmations en tout cas les
annulations ou reports d'opérations
sandrine rollo votre association est une
association de patients atteints de
polyarthrite rhumatoïde mais aussi de
rhumatismes inflammatoires chroniques
elle a pour mission d'aider à mieux
vivre avec ces maladies est ce que
justement des patients vous ont remonté
les difficultés face à ces
déprogrammation nombreuses depuis plus
d'un an maintenant
oui bien entendu parce que dans la
polyarthrite rhumatoïde qui est un des
vrais mathis ma flamme à devoir
chronique
les interventions chirurgicales
essentiellement des poses de prothèses
pour remplacer une articulation qui est
pour eux donc ce sont des interventions
qui sont annulés ou reportés et avec des
conséquences à la fois à court terme
c'est-à-dire pour le patient à brader
des douleurs qui sont qui persistent
puisqu'il n'ya pas l'intervention de l'
angoisse comme on disait je vais être
trois cents ans plus tôt une perte de
mobilité et donc une gêne dans la vie
quotidienne
est ce qu'on craint si à long terme ce
sont des conséquences plus important
parce que c'est du fait de cette absence
de mobilité sont des gens qui n'ont plus
d'activité qui vont devenir sédentaire
et qui augmentent leur risque
cardiovasculaire dans des pathologies
qui sont déjà des pathologies à risque
de complications cardiovasculaires
donc c'est vraiment sûr à court terme et
sur du long terme qui va y avoir des
conséquences assez assez craint
justement la polyarthrite on sait est
une maladie quand même douloureuse qui
est difficile à vivre au quotidien qui
peut provoquer aussi une déformation des
articulations
dans certains cas est ce que ces reports
d'opérations et vous l'avais déjà dit
peuvent entraîner une aggravation
dramatique de la situation face à ces à
cette maladie et du coup hanche et
entraîné une pose de prothèses pour des
patients qui nommerait pas forcément eu
besoin là là c'est surtout comment dire
là c'est l'intervention qui sont comment
dire qu'ils sont des programmes et les
interventions chirurgicales pour des
gens pour lesquels on avait déjà
envisagé des prothèses donc pour
lesquels il est déjà déjà une
fonctionnel et effectivement ça peut
enfin ça va faire que ça va être
beaucoup plus long à ce qu'ils puissent
retrouver une suspension de leur
articulation après mais parlait de
justement excusez-moi nos intérêts sont
plutôt parler justement du fait que les
patients qui ne sont pas soignées qui
n'ont pas leur traitement quotidien à
l'hôpital
vous évoquiez vincent cluzel et les
personnes atteintes de cancer
est ce que c'est le cas également pour
les personnes qui sont atteintes de
polyarthrite
alors la plupart des patients
polyarthritiques non leur traitement à
des fins comment dire son rendez vous
des injections vit toujours à leur
domicile
il ya quelques traitements qui sont
administrés à l'hôpital et après partant
pour la polyarthrite secrètement là on
était dans certains cas changer pour que
justement le ou les passions fils les
avoir chez lui en tout cas c'est ce
qu'il y avait au printemps dernier et
qu'il ne doit sûrement être refaite
entre lesquels il ya des commandes il ya
je crois toujours un maintien stable
déroulement colloque dont la plupart des
patients en vain son plus haut vous
évoquez les personnes atteintes de
cancer mais on pense aussi à aux
personnes atteintes d'obésité
on entend souvent que ces malades sont
les victimes collatérales finalement de
cette crise sanitaire
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir à long terme
des conséquences sur leur santé voire
est vraiment ne le souhaite pas dd c'est
à cause de ces déprogrammation
d'opérations chirurgicales importantes
évidemment évidemment puisque l'obésité
l'obésité est un facteur de risque très
important à la fois pour les maladies
cardiovasculaires le diabète bien
entendu et c'est déprogrammation de
chirurgie bariatrique par exemple
induisent une une insécurité je dirais
chez le ch et le patient et puis des
comorbidités qui sont des fois très
importante
merci sandrine rollo et merci vincent
cluzeau d'avoir été avec nous par
visioconférence sur ce plateau
dans l'actualité est également une roue
blanche ou marche blanche à vélo est
organisée samedi 24 avril de 15h à 16h30
entre vernouillet verneuil et riel en
hommage à antoine gélules triellois de
15 ans le 15 avril dernier le jeune
homme roulait à vélo sur une route en
ligne droite à saint germain en laye
lorsqu'il a été mortellement fauchée par
un camion cyclistes depuis peu à
l'entente cycliste vernouillet verneuil
triel c'est le club qui est à
l'initiative de cette marche blanche à
vélo elle aura également pour objectif
de sensibiliser les usagers de la route
aux règles et au respect mutuel
cyclistes comme automobilistes dans le
reste de l'actualité le chantier du club
le village situé à montigny le
bretonneux avance bien
cet équipement sportif communal dédié au
sport de raquette ouvert depuis 35 ans
avait fermé ses portes fin 2019 pour
travaux un chantier de déconstruction et
de réhabilitation qui a commencé juste
avant la pandémie les travaux ont repris
en début d'année 2021
justin brasier s'est rendu sur place un
chantier de déconstruction et de
réhabilitation le club le village à
montigny le bretonneux se refait une
beauté
le complexe dédié au sport de raquette
date de 1984 il faut donc le remettre
aux normes prochaine étape
transformation et aménagement des locaux
terrains de tennis et badminton seront
déplacés sur une dalle couverte
il ya d'abord la dalle des lices peuvent
ils enfin délice babington qui ce qui va
être cool et ensuite l'armature
métallique qui va recouvrir donc ça sera
complètement refermée ensuite il ya
toute la partie ici interne
donc des sociétés la salle de réception
aussi ici vous êtes dans un hall qui
sera le de l'accueil d'un nouvel
établissement
la première étape du chantier concernait
des travaux de déconstruction l'une des
halles a été entièrement démontées
l'autre va être réhabilité on va
renforcer la structure bois et puis donc
la mettre aux normes et de la mettre en
disque dur pour qu'elle soit
complètement exploitables cette nouvelle
halle accueillera les terrains de deux
nouveautés du complexe le futsal et le
padel de nouvelles pratiques sportives
pour rendre le club le village est plus
attractif qui corresponde aujourd'hui à
des demandes très très fort de la part
des utilisateurs est toujours dans
l'optique de
le dédié aux sports loisirs le nouveau
complexe devrait être livré courant 2022
le montant des travaux s'élève à 6,7
millions d'euros une partie du budget
sera financée par une opération
immobilière des logements qui seront
construits à la place de l'ancienne
halle direction l'agglomération
rambouillet territoire à présent ou
trois nouvelles navettes de transport à
la demande vont s'ajouter aux trois déjà
existante depuis janvier 2021
le but de ce transport permettre à des
personnes des zones rurales d'accéder
aux centres des grandes villes du
territoire les détails castries bergère
aller jusqu'aux centres des grandes
villes peut s'avérer difficile quand on
habite en zone rurale pour pallier ces
difficultés l'agglomération rambouillet
territoire a déployé trois navettes de
transport à la demande en 2020 et 3
supplémentaires en janvier 2021
ce qui porte à six le nombre total de
véhicules en circulation un service
nécessaire
ça représente la capacité de se déplacer
avec son simple téléphone devenir des
traits devenir être pris auprès de chez
soi juste à côté chez soi et d'être
emmené sur un des points phares du
territoire les points de ralliement du
territoire c'est une offre qui
n'existaient pas qu'avant il y avait
rien pour utiliser le transport à la
demande d'une plateforme téléphonique
existe mais aussi une application qui
permet de choisir son art et son arrivée
et son départ
actuellement il fonctionne du mardi au
vendredi de 9h15 à 15 heures 30 et le
samedi de 9h15 à 18h50 à partir du 31
mai il va fonctionner à partir du midi
sur les mêmes horaires que du mardi au
vendredi et le système informatique de
réservation est totalement autonome on
peut réserver jusqu'à un mois al avance
voire une heure à l'avancement et des
banques lui aussi prend ta ou moins
nécessaire d'avoir un trajet la première
personne qui commande le circuit
déclenché la course et ensuite il ya un
algorithme informatique qui permettent
de faire des regroupements de personnes
si des demandes arrivent sur
même trajet après des débuts difficiles
à son lancement le transport à la
demande semble trouver son public
chaque mois la demande augmente de 10%
et le service est entièrement financé
par l'ile-de-france mobilité ce sont les
conseillant les conséquences d'une
guérilla judiciaire avec leur futur
voisinage à à dainville deux éleveurs
qui devait s'établir se sont retrouvés
en situation financière précaire
le département des yvelines est
intervenu en prêtant des terres non
utilisés dans l'ancien haras des
bréviaires
les précisions de bixente mais rien
santisteva ni une solution trouver en
urgence dans l'impossibilité de
s'installer sur leur nouvelle terre à
dainville agathe guerre un fabien le cow
indiqué leurs animaux se sont établies
provisoirement depuis le mois de mars
dans l'ancien haras des bréviaires du
fait du harcèlement judiciaire
la famille d'agriculteurs qui voulait
s'implanter se retrouve sans crédit
bancaire pour pouvoir acquérir ces
terres et pour pouvoir faire les
investissements nécessaires
donc je chante au bord de la faillite de
la ruine des paires prêté par le
département des yvelines qui permettent
aux éleveurs d'abriter leurs bêtes le
temps que la bataille juridique
initiée notamment par l'éditrice odile
jacob ne cesse il ya des vaches il ya
des choses à essayer de faire survivre
notre notre élevage notre activité
agricole
ces prêts car étant power
l'instance est pas la suite des
événements certainement qui va se passer
quelque chose après tout ça l'exemple de
cette famille n'est pas un cas isolé
dans les yvelines
c'est pourquoi le département réfléchit
à une solution plus globale à mettre en
place ce à quoi nous réfléchissons c'est
la création d'un fonds cogéré avec la
chambre d'agriculture qui permettrait de
régler justement ces problèmes parce que
là vous avez une famille qui est
concerné et ça a été très médiatisée
parce que les plaignants contre eux sont
des gens très médiatique mais il ya eu
d'autres exemples identiques quant au
haras des bréviaires qui n'était plus
destiné à accueillir de l'élevage les
élus locaux l'intercommunalité de
rambouillet territoire et le département
étudie des projets de reconversion du
domaine pour le futur un peu d' aventure
pour refermer ce journal le trekking gaz
elle aura lieu du 6 au 11 novembre
prochain
un trek 100% féminin dans le coeur du
désert marocain
ces liens get on go a rencontré une
yvelinoise qui va participer à cette
toute première édition habitante
d'orgeval christelle lemoine va
participer à la première édition du
tracking gazelle avec seulement une
carte une boussole et des coordonnées
géographiques
elle devra rallier chaque jour plusieurs
balises c'est une course d'orientation
mais ce n'est pas une course de rapidité
il s'agit en fait véritablement
d'essayer de faire le moins de
kilomètres possibles donc il faut
trouver via tout le chemin qu'on aura
balisé de toute la journée
la distance la plus courte possible ce
trek 100% féminin organisé par mayenga
une agence événementielle et sportive
est aussi 100% solidaire 5 euros seront
reversés au secours populaire pour
chaque balise trouvé par une équipe
puisque l' aventure se fait à trois
christelle est donc accompagné d'emilie
et de laurence qui habitent en région
parisienne et qui travaille avec
christelle quand elle a su que c'était
un trek
elle a pensé à moi parce qu'elle sait
que j'aime le trek voilà donc le trek la
marche le côté un peu non confortable de
l'endroit aussi
le désert est intéressant et puis le
fait de bivouaquer pour s'entraîner les
deux jeunes femmes font des randonnées
christelle vient entre trois à cinq fois
par semaine dans le bois d'abbécourt à
orgeval l'avantagent de cette oreille
c'est que ça nous permet d'avoir
plusieurs passages avec quelques
dénivelés dont celui ci ce qui nous
permet justement de nous entraîner à
démonter un petit peu compliqué alors
évidemment c'est pas un environnement
sableux mariée et mère de trois enfants
cette quarantenaire avait déjà participé
au rallye automobile en 2019 une
expérience qui l'a beaucoup marqué c'est
une aventure qui est passionnante dans
tous les sens du terme
c'est un beau dépassement de soi
incroyable c'est vraiment pas facile ça
va être physique
après ça va être aussi beaucoup mentale
puisque la fatigue le stress
malgré cela christelle tient à
participer de nouveau à ce rallye cette
fois ci à pied les trois jeunes femmes
sont encore à la recherche de sponsors
pour financer leur aventure c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
l'information revient demain à 18h en
direct dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canale et d'ici là même confiné
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
[Musique]